today we find out if these three
buzzfeeders have what it takes to
persuade strangers on the streets to do
what they need in order to win points
for these two contestants right here I'm
Chris Ortiz and this is Street Wars
what's going on everyone it's your guy
sir abiola and we are live with Street
Wars in Hollywood and I'm gonna let
y'all know today that I'm gonna win this
challenge I've got the personality I've
got the energy I'm looking for fun
people on the streets I'm taking No for
no answer is that right I'm not taking
no for an answer that's what I'm trying
to say so let's get to it
yo what's up I'm Pernell and I'm here in
LA's favorite place Hollywood Boulevard
and I'm here to Win Ben and Carolina
they don't got anything on me if you
want to win you should pick me it's
Carolina we're on Hollywood Boulevard
and you want to pick me because I'm
gonna get people we're gonna win it's
hot I don't care I'm gonna win for you
I can't drop it because it's gonna break
first round you both have started with
100 points on the board that you will
have to wager on one of these three
buzzfeeders round one you have 10
minutes to try to get at least one
person to finish the lyrics you can only
attempt three people in three songs okay
easy
can I swap this one out No No One's
Gonna guess this one this is a Michael
Bolton song all right I don't know that
one either what if I don't know the song
Dancing Queen by Abba this is a good mix
since you've been gone done I think I'm
gonna go with Carolina I'm playing it
safe the first round being strategic I'm
gonna go with 30 of my 100 points I am
gonna still go for her now you're going
with Cardinal and interesting tour 20.
does anyone want to play a game with me
really fast his palms are sweaty his
palms are sweaty anybody have finished
the lyric hello his palms were sweaty uh
knees weak spaghetti mom's spaghetti why
was there mom's spaghetti what happened
how do you get Mom's spaghetti on your
sleeve I got nothing you can spoon feed
the lines that's that's cheating it's
okay we'll do the next one okay okay
come on over here I love me you know
what I want you to say Don't Be Cruel
come on your girl's embarrassing you do
we get a hint no
Carolina no next one let's see if you
get this one you're a superstar yes
that's what you are you know it no no I
know this one it's on the tip of their
tongue they want to say it's so bad
you're a superstar that's what you are
you know it
you should get it it's actually the same
thing twice
Carolina looked like she was about to
strike out but she got it done fairly
let's see how Pernell does though here's
the thing we started out friends it was
cool but it was all pretend I got no
idea man oh my God
little things I should have said and
done I never took the time I have no
idea I'm sorry about that one it's all
good well we are really going down here
this is bad this is really bad hey
what's up what's going on last chance do
you want to finish the lyric please yeah
okay let's go say my days are numbered
but I keep waking up I gotta thank God I
don't know but today seems kind of odd
little things I should have said and
done I never took the time
sorry are you freestyling right now
forget the song I'm about to Freestyle
here's my mixtape gotta respect the
hustle we did not win
this is awkward Caitlyn you wagered 30
points betting on Carolina Ramiro you
wager 20 points betting on Pernell how
do you feel about that now I feel great
a little disappointed a little
embarrassed all right killing you have
130 points Ramiro you are down to 80.
you got to pick it up my friend let's
get into round two you had 10 minutes to
try to get a stranger to take a selfie
with you standing four feet apart on the
stranger's phone they must send it to
you at the end that might be a little
tricky for 200 points you're going to
bet on who blew it I think Pernell blew
it he let me down last time I'm gonna go
with that I trust Carolina a lot let's
see who blew it I'm getting a lot of
meme mucks today yo what's going on man
I love your hair it's giving Joe Dirt
2022 right if I take a selfie with you
bro yeah come on man you're flying bro
today I got it hey my man it was not
four feet he didn't follow rules he's a
rule breaker so therefore he is
disqualified and he blew it hey that's a
really cool shirt you have on that's
also really cool hat yeah I have
confidence in this do you want to take a
selfie together
I'll see I'm gonna help you out a little
bit let's move here oh he's getting the
light up he's aligning it all right
if you can send it to my phone that
would be amazing surprise Pernell did
not blow it how do you feel Ramiro just
speechless at this point okay Caitlyn
you got it right which gives you 330
points and Ramiro you got it wrong it
gives you only 80 points and now it's
time for the weight
each buzzfeeder has 10 minutes to see
how many people you can get to limbo
that's what the stick is for good luck
your time begins now since you're
currently last place you're up first how
many people do you think they got to go
under the stick I am voting for Ben and
I think a solid 22. 22 people yes high
expectations for our boy Ben I'm going
back to my og girl Carolina she has such
a puppy personality and I really think
that she can get a good 25 people
Carolina Ben here we go
behold it is I the limbo King oh he went
in with confidence limbo
[Music]
he's got to put it a little higher
yellow yellow he's having fun with it
for sure you got it oh okay that was a
different type of limbo okay here we go
hey we're doing great so far can we get
a limbo love the energy he's really
getting people in this 30 seconds I need
as many people to limbo
[Applause]
yes we did it Ben got 15 people come on
Carolina at least get more than that
does anyone want to play limbo
[Music]
yes
who's next who's next
she needs to get her spirits up a little
more I got eight minutes left how left
can you go go girl
how look can you go hello can you go I
need her to yell Sarah you're lingering
around you want to play limbo
no acknowledgment I have four minutes
left limbo limbo I got a degree for this
people he's going for it
[Applause]
who wants to
want to go put your backs to good use I
got 30 seconds left anybody limbo
anybody Carolina you only got six people
all right Caitlyn how many points did
you wager on Carolina I wagered 250 of
my points now I had high hopes for
Catalina as well unfortunately she did
not do so well and Ramiro how many
points did you wager on Ben all in 80.
it seems Pernell got 35 people what oh
one we got two we got three I feel like
some of these people aren't even like
choosing to do it he's forced
oh wow I love his energy yeah he's on
fire right now live on live bow live
vote oh my God by the way I think I won
so that means Ramiro you have no more
points Caitlyn you have about 80 points
which means you are the winner of Street
Wars thank you thank you alrighty so
that does it for us today please let us
know in the comments down below which
buzzfeeder you want to see on the
streets next and this was Street Wars I
have butterflies in my stomach how do I
talk to people has anyone ever told you
guys you look like the Jonas Brothers
excuse me sir has anyone ever told you
you look like The Rock
foreign
[Music]